[Musique]
regardez ces femmes ces hommes il y à
quelques heures ils ne se connaissaient
pas encore si nous les avons réunis
c'est parce qu'ils ont tous été filmé
par la télévision il ya 20 ans il ya
vingt ans souvenez vous c'était la fin
de la guerre d'algérie de gaulle
johnny hallyday brigitte bardot au début
des années 60 il était adolescent comme
certains de nos enfants ici présents
qu'est ce que leurs parents leur ont
légué l'avenir et al
[Musique]
belga pourquoi une cas ce que c'est plus
sympathique c'est nous la borde
on peut venir quand veut qu'on a envie
pendant des personnes ni les parents ni
les voisins dans les appartements c'est
beaucoup mieux comme un pape allemand
on me oui c'est mieux c'est parce que
justement d'en être pas des voisins on
peut jusqu'à l'heure jusqu'à leur
n'importe quelle heure et vous y venez
souvent mais très souvent se seront
possibles
[Musique]
19 fois sur 20
et vous aimez votre métier oui ça j'aime
beaucoup c'est vous qui l'avez choisi
oui c'est moi qui ai choisi c'est à dire
c'est un peu tout le monde autour de moi
j'avais rien d'autre à faire quand quand
j'ai eu à choisir la branche sud avec
l'angleterre pour apprendre l'anglais
jeffrey être journaliste et puis j'ai
pas pu malheureusement changé travailler
tout de suite
vous n'avez pas pu à 18 heures comme ça
vous avez décidé premiers pas dans la
liste et qu'il valait mieux pas dire
journaliste est passé d'un métier qui
rapporte pas assez pour moi tout de
suite il fallait que je gagne assez
d'argent lors la légalité
[Musique]
geci connaît parfaitement son métier et
tout ce qu'elle m'a appris juste tout ce
que je sais jusqu'à présent cette année
seulement qu'on a pris alors finalement
elle a de l'importance
je la tenue et vous souhaiteriez lui est
simple oui n'en travaille vite we win xp
qu'elle y être mais parce que comme
alors j'espère plus qu'être comme
l'hymne york post et oui oui d'ailleurs
comme tous les clients de shaw coach que
je coche je n'y serais jamais et bien si
cliente elle l'est devenue la dernière
une vallée réa patron niveau de votre
problème
quand j'avais 20 ans c'était plus facile
au niveau de l'expression plus facile au
niveau des ambitions des objectifs qu'on
pouvait avoir
on avait là moi j'avais la sensation que
je pourrais tout faire je trouve que la
société dans laquelle on vit totalement
responsable de la jeunesse jeudi à
chaque génération est un je prends un
exemple ici ce magasin on j'ouvre un 9
heures je ferme à 7h30
effectivement je suis fatigué
effectivement je n'arrive pas toujours à
mes fins de mois donc je dis c'est pas
une réussite mais ça n'est pas bon non
plus de se plaindre parce que ça
démobilise les enfants ils se disent bon
bah quoi bon puisque toute façon elle
trime et finalement elle n'y arrive pas
alors ça sert à quoi
alors il rêve c'est partir sous les
cocotiers enfin ils ne sont pas penchées
dans la réalité
henriette est divorcée elle élève sa
fille valérie 13 ans et son fils bruno
âgé de 20 ans
j'ai passé 4 je vais prendre un avion
qui vaille vachement moins je suis resté
là bas après je serai mieux quand même
si toi ça sent pas bon je sais pas il ya
des fois c'est cinq ans dont trois sur
moi vraiment bien s'éclater tous les
genres appareil pourra leur plein de
pognon
si j'avais plein prix l'ordre est bien
en parler tout mais l'a pour l'instant
ce coaching
moi j'suis pas de bail que je passais
d'études
tu vois kapalua hawaii
pourquoi tu as récemment n'a pas plus de
montagne non on l'a été ce projet du
temps parce que j'aurai passé le bac
n'est pas rien en attendant je suis pas
pressé le bac j'y vais j'y travaille et
j'ai gagné de l'argent la manche et
d'argent de côté
tout d'abord monde je vais avoir des
groupes cotés que je vais partir loin du
combat qui m'aurait jamais permet -
carizza est en bois en tête dans des
brûlots ta mère et les lancia se marier
avoir des enfants d'avoir une maison et
c est ce que tu pense à toi ali marier
avoir des enfants restés ici certains
ici donc je pense pas à ça je pense
avoir des enfants j'ai envie d'avoir des
mots c'est pas pour ça que je veux me
marier faire un mot ni fait de la villa
bon sinon ça y est je suis déjà dedans
je veux c'est faire un jeu toi je vais
essayer ça se trouve je vais croiser
demain je vais peut-être partir là bas
tu aimes te ment matin j'ai vraiment
rien c'est sûr je pense partir en
afrique aia me dis que je vais pas me
prendre un coup de hache sur la glace en
rien jamais dans ce pays là où je
connais rien n'est sûr je suis conscient
c'est l'impression que même si je rate
je serais quand même beaucoup s'y sont
enrichis cours restant ici on s'est
tellement passé jusqu'à temps que je
veux tu tombé dans le piège des parents
copains à savoir que j'ai cru qu'il
était très bon justement de tout
démystifier de donner beaucoup de
responsabilité de lui donner des
responsabilités de laisser le droit de
choisir ce qu'il veut et caetera et
c'était une erreur
je dirais dramatique parce que à l'âge
de 16 ans un garçon n'est pas capable de
choisir exactement ce qui est bon pour
lui
en tant que parent il est impossible de
ne pas être angoissé à notre époque
parce que même si on a des enfants qui
ne touche pas aux riches on se dit non
non c'est super pour les autres
malheureusement tout le monde en parle
finalement ça éveille la curiosité et
j'ai pas si on n'a pas 80% qu'il tombe
dans le tram 1
maintenant ils sont beaucoup plus bas et
évidemment cette société de consommation
on leur donne tout mais on leur donne
tout le superficiel finalement
[Musique]
j'ai mes ambitions mais je ne préfère
pas en parler c'est peut-être un peu ce
qui arrange mon père comme ça le jour où
j'y arrive très bien personnes et aux
cantons munitions au prix de ma réussite
le jour où je n'y arrive pas personne
n'est surpris non plus parce qu'une
personne s'attendent à ce que ce que
j'ai choisi un an tu as des ambitions
oui qu'est ce que c'est devenir moniteur
de tennis des jeunes pour avoir une
bonne situation à l'intérieur
confortable et bien meublé bien le bien
vivre et puis ne pas être dans le dos
par ap soucis d'argent
georges et le père d'éric il est chef de
vente dans un grand garage parisien
voilà voyez ça c'est
mon ancien quartier voilà le lot 6 voilà
où je vais demeurer où j'ai passé une
bonne partie de ma jeunesse c'est le cas
de dire puisque j'ai été jusqu'à 23 ans
vous aimeriez revenir ici non je pense
pas non je pense pas parce que toute
façon je n'y retrouverait pas les mêmes
garçons et puis non je crois que
maintenant non je suis très content d'y
avoir demeuré un chacun a eu sa jeunesse
chacun de la savourer pleinement sa
façon moi je me suis bien plus dans mon
quartier j'ai j'ai aimé beaucoup de
quartiers oui tout ça c'était la zone
avant lé pas de billets pas tous ces
immeubles
lorsqu'il faisait que c'était des
terrains vagues qui était libre alors il
y avait évidemment beaucoup de
beaucoup d'animations roule et adoptent
et son petit fils aime ces amusements
dijon ii de sortir jean baucou quoi je
me sortir ou rentrer papin avec des
copains avec des filles quand ça se
présente oui je sortais pourquoi avec
les filles oui j'essaye le plus ou moins
sortir avec les filles oui parce que
j'aime mieux être en compagnie de fric
avec je sais pas où je déteste sortir
avec mes copains quoi mais je me
sentirai des filles pour et puisque ça
se comprend
écoute je connecte makengo
quand je vois ça je me trouvais un peu
partout il y en a il y en a partout
heureusement un majeur j'ai des majeurs
majorité c'est à 21 ans et pathé il
sortait beaucoup avec les filles je ne
trouve pas entendu chanter sar mais là
j'avais été coincé pendant neuf ans
je vous l'avais écrit oui j'essaye
beaucoup et je t'ai important dans vos
conneries oui une somme que quand elle
rit elle commence à marcher
ouais c'est poker commence à marcher
mais c'est que je marque des points quoi
et quand vous sortez avec elle c'est
vous qui payez mousser la table on
dispose j'ai constamment changer
d'ailleurs c'est moi je vais en
difficulté mais quand j'en avais plus
bas si vraiment j'ai confiance en ma
fille je demande
et bah si ça me gêne un peu quoi parce
que chez nous le demande a une fille
cool c'est vrai pour un faux problème
quoi quoi quoi qu'est ce que c'est pour
payer pour lancer ses propres choix pour
moi je vois et mais quelle mauvaise foi
pour normand pour sa maman c'était
connaissent peu de temps après alors là
c'est encore là mais là c'était
nécessaire là j'y pense mais j'ai réussi
ce qu'il soit plutôt intelligente que
oui pourquoi pas ce que nous faisons que
c'est lui ou c'est plus un treizième
devant une commune elle même un peu
moins belle mère dit je vous préviens
c'est d'ailleurs c'est bien parti puis
des gens qui sont plus intelligents quoi
ça tire un peu sur la nonchalance
qu'avait qu'avait dutronc penser on se
trouve cet état jean pierre lhonneur de
comédie il a un truc il s'était inspiré
de la méthode
ça y est de 30 était dragueur mais des
genres et que quand on s'est connu tu
étais avec une autre on trouve quelque
chose
non mais moi j'ai le coeur comme un
artichaut parce que non mais dragueur
veut dire quoi de rigueur
si tu étais drague on t'a dit il ya une
petite blondinette qui est arrivé au
quatrième c'était moi tu as assez vite
ce temps là bien qu'elle ait jamais allé
la voir comme ça qui m'a
faut faire
[Musique]
ma
c'est un monde
le temps
[Musique]